TFUE DID OOPSIE!!
TATI DID OOPSIE!!
AAND
YOUTUBE DId ooptie.
My name is Mary Ham!
Good evening!
And welcome to Pew News!
It's Ham--mer time!
♪ Pew News intro ♪
Good evening! Welcome to £00 News!
M a r y  h a m !
Our first story comes from Tfue!
Tfuel??
''Who is Tfue?'', you might ask.
It's the guy that looks like the Fortnite guy
*Chuckles into demonitization*
What a coincidence!
He's got 10 million subscribers on YouTube. (10<96)
He is THE Fortnite guy right now.
Ninja? Ëxcüsë më!
*cough/laugh* It's all about Tfue now!
Although, maybe not for long, Ninja! (#notsponsered)
Don't worry
because TFUE IS LOSING SUBSCRIBERS :0
Oh. My. God.
What did Tfew dew?
T-Tfue do? Tfue doo...?
🎵 What did Tfuel do? 🎵
OOH
Well, Tfue is suing FaZe.
FaZe which is the clan...
I don't know what it is. I never rea-
It's a-
I think it is a clan
You see how he has that little logo there?
That means he's part of FaZe.
ᵀʰᵃᵗ ᵐᵉᵃⁿˢ ʰᵉ ᶦˢ ˢᵘᵖᵉʳ ᵍᵒᵒᵈ ᵃᵗ ᵍᵃᵐᵉˢ, ˢᵘᵖᵉʳ ᵖʳᵒ
And now he's SUING them. That's crazy!
Ever since T fue has stopped uploading or
doing his streams
In the report, it says that his contract with Faze is one-sided
But I think the thing main the people are focused about  here is the 80% thing
DrdDisrespect: One of the world's top professional E-sports players is suing his gaming organization for allegedly restraining his business opportunities at taking up to
(*^*)
80%!!!
*pewds laughing from behind
Hey, he's got my glasses
*no*
Daddy?
80 pewcent
so, apparently...
Faze this clan-
this management- for Tfue
*WARNING TAKE OFF YOUR EARPHONES*💀
has been TAKING 80%!! 80%
it  also says that they have been limiting
sponsored deals obtained through this team
basically, he can only do
sponsorships through FaZe😬
I think that's how I understand it
and T fue spoke a few days prior about sort of-
not working with companies and you should just be independent
Tfue: if you're in the world cup or you think you're going to qualify,
do not sign to an org unless- it says in the contract...
...that...
...they don't take any earning from tournaments
And if you're IN a contract that says that,
you need to frickin' get a laywer and get the flip out of that contract
Oh my God, that's what T's doing!
Tfue did say though that he is getting all his prize earnings:
I keep all my earnings? Yeah.
But why are other people mad at Tfue then?
It makes no sense if they take
80% that's really bad.
He also says that he was,
"reportedly pushed into living in one of the group's LA homes alongside other young celebs."
"Nobody:
Literally nobody:
Not a single s'soul:
Tfue:
tHeY fOrCeD mE tO LiVe iN a mAnSiOn fOr fReE
hOw cOuLd tHeY!!1!1"
*laugh*
I mean, he could've been threatened,
or...
"oR iF yOuR nOt pArT oF tHe tHiNg"
*rambling*
To be fair, I- we don't know what's going on.
And it gets even WEIRDER.
He also says that he was,
"encouraged to drink alchohal
while underage".
Tfue was twenty years old at this time.
Shut the frikc up okay you're drinking already. (oof)
People were very quick to point this out.
Even in his own videos.
*music*
Person: "Yo what the hekc there's snow up here!" ("iT sNoWs iN KoReA" no shit sherlock)
Tfue: "Yeah guys I don't really drink," Felix in the background: OH
Tfue: "but I am having one beer." Felix in the background: EXPOSED
"aY yO i dOn'T rEaLlY dRiNk"
Sounds what a drinker would say.
People: "LET'S GO BABY LET'S GO!"
*cheering*
*more cheering as Tfue chugs down alcoholic drinks*
According to the NIAAA
"60 percent of youth admit to drinking at least one drink by the time they are 18 years old."
Now I would never,
absolutely never,
encourage underage people to drink,
but it's also...
...you're full of bullcrap
per :) (he technically didn't curse)
uhhhh...
he also said that he was
"continuously pressured"
"to perform stunts" in his videos.
like, why is- are they bringing this up
In a legal-
dispute
It really seems like grasping for straws if you bring this up
And Faze Banks,
One of the founders of Faze,
addressed this as well.
Faze Banks: "-fucking sick of."
Faze Banks: "You jump off of shit,"
Faze Banks: "You've been doing that far, far, far before."
Faze Banks: "you met us."
Faze Banks: "The first thing you did when you came to LA,"
Faze Banks: "the very first thing you did,
Faze Banks: "was that you brought us up to the reservoir and you jumped off of the whole reservoir."
Faze Banks: "If anyone was pressuring anybody into doing that,
FB: "It was you."
FB: "Pressuring Tommy, his brother,"
FB: "Quit into it"
Tfue: "Adapt, if you don't jump, you'll have to jump with one of us."
Tfue: "Alright?"
P: Got'em
Apparently, FaZe Banks and Tfue are friends
and he got very upset about this lawsuit, seeing it as a big betrayal,
and I think that's why this whole story really blew up so much
And Banks addresses the whole 80/20% split saying that
FB: Absolutely 1000% untrue.
Uh, the short answer is, we have collected and earned $60,000
from Tfue since we, um, originally started our relationship, which was about a year and a half ago
Keem: Well that's definitely not 80%, HUE HE
FB: So I don't even- I dont even think thats
80% of what Tfue makes in a day
PDP: So basically saying that all FaZe has done is collected 60,000 from him
which has been through brand deals, and in those brand deals,
They haven't taken 80%, they have taken 20%
Which is still, in the higher end
but, its not that bad
But, I think the important distinction here is that, on T fue's contract,
It says that, that they can take 80%
its just the fact that they haven't done that
But contractually,
I understand why T fue wants to get out of this contract
it sounds like a bogus contract, if that's the case,